Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Prison Architect
Now, this is
really going to be interesting
because i don't know...
what else there is to tell about the story of this game
but i'm eager to find out.
it's really interesting because it caught me so quickly off guard
i knew
that it was going to be about building prison(s) and i kinda like exploded about this last episode
but I wanted to collect my thoughts and reiterate it more
I did not know
this was this type of game, and that's why it caught me so off guard
and that's why suddenly-
I'm very excited to play it
because I usually don't get surprised
going into a game, it's fascinating to me
that it started off this way, I mean
obviously---
it's simple if you think about it
the idea of a prison...
is.....
*Phone ringing*
......
Kind of a touchy subject
It involves
incarcerating human beings, and--
they have thoughts and feelings too, and they have backstories
even if they did commit crimes, they have.....
they're real people
"Demolishing those buildings will take a while you can pass the time more quickly by using the buttons under the clock".
Okay, I already knew about that
if there's one thing Markiplier knows
it's how to pass the time without actually putting any work into it
So,
that's besides the point
but I need to cure--
errr- hire some doctors, because...
A--
PPARentlyyyyyy---
Where's my infirmary? There we go
Apparently---
BOINK!
Do I just need the one?
Ohhh.....
they're healing up
oh, they still--- they still have their hoses
man, those are some epic hoses on those firemen
Alright, so those firemen are gonna be dismissed, and I got a doctor in here that can help
THE DON
however the hell that happened
I imagine that someone started the fire
to try to KILL--
THE DON
But I don't know about that.
Hire more workmen to speed up demolition, okaaaaaay
I can do that
man, that's a lot of workmen already, where do I put 'em
I guess I can put 'em in storage, I suppose
Boink!
BOINK!
Boink..
Woooooooooow, look at 'em gooo
*laughter* they're all tired..
TOO BAD! WORK HARDER, YOU SLAVES!!
I run a prison here, not a charity case!
ERRH!!!
Okay.. anyway..
But I can take care of this Don..
He is my baby and I shall love him forever...
WOW, I can zoom in REAL close.
Alrighty then.
So we got that..
and we need to hire a couple of doctors
Sorry, I did not know that...
Boink!
Okay, so now we got twooooo.....
.... LOVELY doctors- shiiet, didn't mean to do that.
*phone ringing again*
Now we got THREE doctors for noooo reason. *phone continues ringing*
*looks at sidebar* ..... SACK.
SAAAAAAAAAAAAAACK.
Alright, fine. *finally answers ringing phone*
"Good work- " Thank you!
"Let's check up on our casualty."
Uh oh...
Oh boy..
He's turning into Two-Face....
Beebida boop?
Beebida boop boop????
Uh oh.
Well that don't look good.
Those better be his- oh.
They here to finish him off?
*sounds of quiet heart monitor from the game*
*sounds of the heart monitor picking up speed*
Uh oh!
UH OH.
UH OH!!!
*heart monitor still beating erratically*
Uh oh...
...Oh.
Hey, Don!
Oh, hey, how's it going. *music gets louder*
EUueueueuueueuue
Oh jeez.
*reading* "I think he's trying to say something."
Ohh jeeeez.
*reading, while laughing* "Which of you cock-sucking"-- woooh my goddd
Oooohhh!
Woah!
Don! Calm down!
It's not a big deal!
You just got burned alive!
It's fine..!
*reading with accent* "No one did this to ya, pappy. It was an accident."
Oh, jeez.
Don, calm down..!
Don, jeez!
Eugh.
*reading* "Shut your stinkin' mouth and listen good, the both of you."
*reading* "If I knew which one of you fucks started that fire, I'd snap your stinking neck."
*reading* "But my time is done".
*reading* "I'm gonna die in this fucking bed."
*reading* ".. And there's a family business to run."
*reading* "The Palermo name is all we've got left."
*reading, starts laughing* "So you do the honorable thing, you dirty piece of shit fucks, Capiche?"
Uh, yeah, we capiche!
We capiche REAL good!
*reading* "We know what to do, Paps."
Huh.
Why is he in jail with BOTH of his sons?
That's a good question...
Oh..
*chuckles* Man..
Oh, man, these take TURNS!
*LOUD MARK GIBBERISH*
*reading* "Watch your fucking back."
*reading* "This isn't over, Nico!"
Oh.
*laughing* O...kay..
Ooh.
*reading* "Without food-" YEAH LET'S JUST SHIFT GEARS HERE
Don't worry about all that was happening, Mr. Ceo!
Don't you worry your pretty little beard about it!
*reading, again* "Without food, these inmates will be tearing down the walls within a couple days."
*reading* "We've got to secure the prison before we end up with a riot on our  hands."
*reading* "This is the Deployment screen. From here you can control the tactical deployment of all your guards."
Well! Handy that!
I like this.
*reading* "Deploy and spread of guards to all cell blocks and rooms.  Assign ten guards to stations around the prison"
*reading* "That should be sufficient show of strength for now."
*reading* "I also don't want a patrol -- or I WANT a patrol in the inner courtyard where we'll be building the new facilities."
Okay!
Words are getting harder to say.
*reading* "Any time you're unsure what to do, highlight the objective and you'll see additional instructions."
*deep breath* Alrighty, then, let's deploy the guards.
Uh, let's see.
No canteens accessible.
...No canteens?
... Wait.
Guard patrols!
I was suppos'd to have guards patrol in the inner courtyard.
Haboink!
BBLBLBLBLBLBL!!!!!
AAAAND....
EEEERRRGHh!! That'll be good patrols, probably. I hope so. Maybe, maybe not.
Alright, how 'bout this.
Oh!
I CAN do that!
*high pitched* boink!
*highER pitched* boink!
*lower pitched* boink.
boink. x4
boink. x5
boink. x6
boink. x7
boink. x8
boink. x9
aaaaaaaaaaand...
that's all I need, that's ten.
Yay! I did it.
Okay.
..Wait, I thought-
....Hey...
Can I- eueu-hey wait a minute.
Ah!
Oh!
YEEEAH!
I 'unno how I did that, but I did a good.
EEeaaaahh!!!
I'm good at playin' this game... probably not.
*reading* "We've a lot of work still to do. We need to turn our attention to replacing the kitchen and the canteen."
Maybe that should've been the first priority that we should've done before we worried about riots on our hands.
*reading* "First, we need to rebuild the kitchen. You'll need to install several pieces of equipment"
*reading* "and hire some chefs."
*reading* "Once that's done build a new canteen, once you have all that completed the chefs will automatically start preparing meals for the entire prison."
Handy, that.
They're nice.
*reading* "If you aren't sure what to do at any time, try highlighting the objective in the to do list to see some hints".
Do you not know who I am??
My name is Markiplier and I absolutely
NEEEVER
follow any instructions
and I just go willy nilly on what I wanna do
and then COMPLAIN when things don't go my way.
So, Mr. CEO, you back the FUCK off.
Thank you very much.
Okay, so we need to build a kitchen.
Which I'm gonna figure out riiiight
about now
I'm gonna build it in the shadow of the destroyed version.
Ha-ba!
Well shit I can't seem to do-
I can't seem to do that.
Why can't I do that.
What's wrong.
Whaaat's the big deal?
Why can't I build a kitchen here?
I'm tryin' real hard.
It's-
Why isn't it letting me build a kitchen?
Waaait a minute.
Somethin' ain't right here.
What's- uh this is..
THIS IS SOME BOLOGNA HERE!
I'm not much appreciatin' this.
How the frick do I-
Why's it not doin'??
Maybe can't- No, it doesn't..
*deep breath*
*frustated* I don't know
WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM ME..
Indoors.. cooker.. fridge..  OHhh!
Duuhh!!
I'm stupid!
I need to build the building first!
Duh- oh man. I'm so silly.
Oh man, I almost completely forgot about that.
You actually need the building first and THEN you can put things inside of it.
So now I need to build the room..
With da-the kitchen..
But this needs to actually be built FIRST.
It can't be built yet..
It's, uh, not quite there.
So..
Objects..
Large..
Jail.. door..
I SUPPOOOOOOOOOSE
This... needs.. to be there?
I guess there's no other door to have.
Eh, I could do a normal door.
Staff door..
There we go.
Ah, yeah, that'll be good.
Okay, lock door.
Right about... Boink!
Okay.
And then..
Once- Wow, look at them go.
Alright- speed up!
Speed up, speed up
We gotta get hungry prisoners fed.
That's the most important thing in our lives right now.
Ooh, this is interesting because now
I get free form on whatever I wanna do.
Nice.
*giggles*
Ok.
So now that we've got that...
Those are built..
Requires entrance..
We'll get that in a second.
Objects..
J- jail door, I guess?
I guess this would require jail doors.
Boinkity
Boinkity.
Eugh, 'scuse me, that crept up on me an' I apologize.
Okay, so now I can make this
Into a kitchen.
Haa-bifffky!
Nice!
And then I can make the canteen in here- oh it's not done yet.
Ok, so this needs a bunch of ob-jeck-ts.
Like.
Cooookers
Cookers, cooker- whoop. Cookers.
Cookers. Cookers. Cookers? Cookers! Ok.
Fridge.
Uhhh..
Let's put it on the south side.
Friiidge.
Fridge
Fridge?!
Fridge????
Sink????
ssssssssssssink
sink!
Excellent placement!
No one's going to be inconvenienced by this at all!
And theeeen...
Trash can by the door, boinkity boink.
Alright, that looks good.
Failed, need a fridge and a sink- it's almost there!
Bear with me.
And then in here...
We make THIS into the CANTEEN.
*markiplier noises*
Okay, we got that.
*more markiplier noises*
Okay, we need some lighting in this other place, too.
Lights, please!
Boink, boink, boink, boink, boink.
Wait why can't I- oh, I couldn't do that? Oh.
Sorry!
Bing-bing, okay.
Bing.
Bing...
Bing.. bing... bing.. bing.. bing.. Bing!
Alright, that should be good enough for that.
Then I need to connect it with the power in the utilities grid.
Electrical grid.
Connect dat and.. dat and then..
..that? And that should be enough, right?
No, these need their OWN power..
Bing bong bing bong?
Bing bong bing bong I think that's good enough for thaaat.
And then it needs- it looks like it needs... pipe, too..
They're probably going to give me a tutorial about that later, but I'm just doing that preemptively so I actually do what I need to do.
And then this needs to go all the way in here..
Probably just needs to go all the way in here too.
Brrum, alllrriiiight!
We got that done!
The kitchen is doing... well enough, apparently it wants me to do the floor differently. Well fine..
Let's get a nice white tile going on in there.
Boink!
And then we'll do.. matching..
Oh, let's get- let's give our prisoners something nice! Let's give them a FANCY tile.
THAT'S what they're looking for.
Okay, so that's almost done..
ok so that's almost done now
Now- woah, hey! Woah!!
whoa hey whoa whoa whoa it's not ready
yet come on now it's not ready
Woah, WOAH!!!! It's not ready yet! COME ON, NOW!
It's not ready!
There's no food!
there's no food no food come on what are
you doing
There's no food, come on, what're you doin'!
I don't even have CHEFS!
I don't even have chefs, cooks both the
boot
Alright, cooks..
Bap boop bep boop... bapboopbeboop!
*singing* I hope that's enough~. I don't know how many I neeeed.
Alright, now we need tables.
tables about.
How about
Boink x1
Boink x2
Boink Boink Boink Boink x6
Uh oh. Welp. They're done there.
Boink boink Boink boink boink x11
*more markiplier gibberish*
Okay, and then they need benches to sit on..
ok and then they need benches to sit on
No, that's a DOOR..
*more gibberish*
boop boop beep
-Aaah fuck..-
*returns to gibberish* Bink bonk bink bonk
*gibberish*
Ah, fuck *gibberish*
Aaaaand serving tables.
Eeehhh right..
Uh--- right
hh... ... there? and..
there... and..
THERE aaaaaand...
There!
Is that good enough???
Did I do good????
I installed foour..
Oh- connect the sinks to the water mains, okay..
Large pipe..
Need to go.. here?
Like that?
Is that good enough?
Did that d'yo it?
Oh.. no.. that needs small pipe.
Ok... small pipe.
Bleh!
Ok, how 'bout that!
Let's see if someone actually goes and do their job!
is anybody gonna do their job
Anybody over here, huh?
Wha'? Heh? Huh?
what ya huh?
It looks like we need a bin.
For the canteen.
Put these down here..
Wheely bins... Wheely bins
Boink okay so we got our wheely bins and we got the   fridges
stocked with nice food and not the water
main just yet but there, okay
yeah we did all that we needed to do
correct? Oooh  the CEO's calling I hope he's
here to praise me and not the discipline
me. "You would not believe what I've just
been told".
I might why what happened is there
another fire all huh
"Our guys were dumping some of the old
food stuff they discovered packs of"
"narcotics and bottles of alcohol hidden
in the crates".
I don't believe it I don't believe it at
all. "We'd suspected the Palermo family of"
"smuggling into the facility for some
time now we've never been able to"
"determine how some days it doesn't rain it pours".
ok good.... Isn't that good?
"Don Victor Palermo boss of one of  the East
Coast most feared mob families"
uh-huh
"The Palermo's eluded the FBI for decades..."
I didn't know that it was story time but
thanks grandpa
"Anthony Palermo the Dons eldest son and
natural heir ran the day-to-day-"
"-operations. Nico Tamoretti i wasn't a
made man but was welcomed into the"
"family business when he married the Dons
only daughter Vatalia. And Sunny Palermo"
"The Don's second son"
"the runt of the litter temper like a pitbull and only half as smart"
"Their empire ran a narcotics trade from
Maine to Florida"
"That was until Anthony got called caught
in flagrante delicto." oh I don't know what
that means
Flagrante? Oh
Oh
oh it's connected
I didn't know that. "Shot dead by a
jealous husband."
"Unfortunately for the family police at
the scene found 12 kilos of uncut"
"cocaine in Anthony's sports bags"
that's a lot of cocaine *gasps* "And the
evidence led straight to the top."
Oh was that like in the picture and I
just didn't see it before
Ohh that's no bueno
oh it's all connected I had no idea
"Overnight everything the Palermo family had built up crumbled to the ground"
"the FBI and everything they need to do
ensure they'd all rot in jail".
Well, then, bye Vitalia you have a good day.
"Which leaves Vitalia the Don's daughter
the only living member of the family"
"wasn't behind bars"
"we don't know much about her other than
she was always kept outside the family"
"business. But somebody on the outside
must have been sending those drugs in".
Somebody
why would they send them into the prison
of all places to send drugs
why into the prison. "We could have quite
serious narcotics problem on our hands"
here. But we can't deal with that just
yet."
"We've got our kitchen and canteen up and
running our chefs will work on preparing"
"food for everyone which should cool
things down"
"I'm concerned that the fire was clearly
deliberate and we don't want a repeat of"
"that install a sprinkler system over the
new kitchen and canteen and connect them"
to the water mains". Can do boss, will do that
"All prisoners have needs.  Those needs
directly impact how your prisoners"
"behave right now everyone is starving
under and that's what all shouting has"
"been about food is one of their highest
priority needs and you ignore it at your"
"own peril."
"A prison is just a few failed meals away
from a wall to wall riot"
"you can monitor the needs of all your
prisoners from the needs report which"
"you can normally access through the
reports icon at the bottom of the right."
"This report shows the combined needs of
all your prisoners"
"red means a lot of prisoners are angry
about a particular need not being met."
"As you'd expect food is red for
virtually everyone but these prisoners"
"are also very bored recreation needed
and the prison is also in pretty shabby"
"state which is reflected in their"
"environment and clothing needs." Oh ok.
"It's your decision as the resident"
"prison architect which needs to..."
will you "...will try to attend to first you
can install televisions yourself to keep"
"them occupied and hire some janitors
clean up the place or you can just"
"ignore your prisoners needs all together
and rely on force to keep the prison"
"under control."
"I'll leave it up to you."
Wow that's
it's so bizarre i really appreciate, I'll
pause it real quick real
I really appreciate the fact that it intermingles the story and functional
concepts of the game it brings like your
you in the game it draws you in with the
story that was unexpected when you go
into this
who would think that there would be a
story here that's actually interesting
and actually has substance there but
then it intermingles it with the
construction aspect of actually
maintaining the game itself and that's
very cool because at the core of a game
the gameplay has to be the paramount so
this could just be a prison architect
and be like the objective could just be
"Oh make as much money as you can"
but that's not all it is here and that's
really cool
anyway that's all I want to say about
that anyway carrying on back to the dick
jokes and fart boxes alright.
Where are we?  What are we doing?
ok we need a new sprinkler system.   Objects... Sprinkler...
pump pump
boink boink oh I doubled up I'll
accidentally doubled up the and that's
no bueno
I i accidentally doubled up the lights
in the other place and the lights in
this place as well I didn't need that
many lights so i can actually destroy
those
no I'm going ok that's gonna be fine
okay so install a couple of sprinklers
connect the sprinklers to the water so
many connecting with pi-ipes
where are they? Right there... right there...
so we're going to connect another big
water main because we need him in both
categories and we need pipes going in
here
I wonder if they will if I have to get
right over them i'm not on it wasn't sure
about that
here we go and that should do it
okay that should be it right?  That'll be
good? okay hopefully
let's see if that goes have a mum pum
pum pum ba-ba-boom ba-ba boom
I mean that should be enough god damn
and I was one off . okay
good enough good enough good enough.. boink boink boink. Okay got that
and that should be good alright.
So. connect the sprinklers, handle the food
needs of your prisoner, handle the
recreational needs, so where do i put in
things for stuff like free time
oh I guess I could put it in the yard
that's a thing. Ohh people are screaming
ohh people are not happy, this guy is
tired and resting
he's standing in the middle of the cell
block resting. Hey Aston huh
are you doing your you look very unique
compared to everybody else happens to
just be a circle
all right but everyone seems to be very
angry so I'm gonna give them something
to do
weight bench so they can get stronger and
eventually beat the shit out of all the
guards that sounds good yup boink
ok tvs in their cells can put TVs in all
of their cells that wouldn't be I
wouldn't even be possible
could I do that I could probably do that
if I can do that
maybe I'm gonna be the benevolent prison
architect and i'm really going to care
about my guys
I mean that would be really interesting
i don't think that's what I'm gonna do
but here we go
and yeah yeah and especially this guy he
seems especially grumpy
ok only that cell block is going to get
TVs because I can't be bothered to put
TVs in all of your cells
that's just ridiculous how could I do
that that's absurd that you would even
think that it's possible
[phone rings]
here comes the CEO. "We had an incident in
the showers..." oh no there's a body
"Actually, there's two bodies luckily for
us we've got cameras in there when you"
"get a moment click on the Polaroid in
the showers and we'll take a look at"
"what happened".
Ok let me get to that in just a second
i'm taking care of the needs are they
naked
oh I know who these are that's the guy
that married Vitaly
all right that doesn't look a danger
whoo-hoo dangers I and increasing who
all right you know what I'm gonna give
you all tvs because I'm just feeling so
darn generous actually how about maybe
bookshelves
maybe bookshelves I can't be bothered to
do everything for you guys.  Boink
boink boink boink boink boink boink boink
bink bonk bink bonk boink
okay you got books they got TV you're
going to be better off because you're
going to be learning that with a holding
cell doesn't look very fun
the holding cell looks grimy as shit can
I get some janitorial staff or something
yeah janitors
all right ah mmm
bu.. bu..bu..bu..bu.. bu..boinkity boinkity
boinkity boinkity I don't know if placing
him actually affects what they do but
hopefully it's okay and it's gonna get a
little cleaned up because man this place
is just rancid oh my goodness gracious
I didn't even bother to look at that I
thought that was just part of the
facilities
oh my god it's so gross!  ugh!  well that's
enough i'm gonna need an army of you
bastards
whoo woof woo
ok so they got that hopefully some of
these cells are gonna clean up but I
don't know about that
I'm wondering if because they're less
happy all calm down stop getting out
there
you're gonna need to calm your tits we
got food on the way it's gonna take a
little longer i'm going to get a few
more of these guys going . wow they are
angry *Markiplier grunts and noises*
hopefully there's enough food for
everybody but I don't know literally
they're only eatin' bacon but at least the
needs are going down the old danger is
decreasing which is nice
ok the recreational needs still need to
be addressed though I mean they got TV
is what more do you want more can I do
I'm just one man! Shop front? radio? pool table?
I guess in the yard they can play pool
in the yard
Can't they do that?  That's possible you
don't know
drain in the yard for all the blood
that's going to be pumping out of it
I don't know go have fun have fun you
guys have fun have fun
alright so the
so that's good
ok handle the needs of your recreational
that's getting better
seventy-six percent the environmental
needs are getting slowly up i just don't
have enough janitors just yet
I'm gonna hire a bunch of janitors and
hopefully it will get cleaned up quicker
and then I'll fire some janitors that I
don't need so many
I can I sack you what are you doing
there what are you doing this guy dead
why are you just bouncing on the radio
you weirdo who served 12 and a half of
72 years wow
grievous bodily harm wow that is -- woah
woah that is rap sheet
holy crap.  All right, is it getting clean
yet?  Good god it's still not clean my
goodness gracious these janitors need to
hurry the hell up
it's at sixty percent o handle the needs
the food needs but the food needs but I
did
recreational needs are done, how do the
food needs go down
damn it eat you bastards
all right eat up maybe do I need more cooks?
I think I might need more cooks not that
cooks cook cooks...
I just don't know how many cooks you
absolutely need 92 96 96 and bam ok now
we're going to click on the polaroid
before it can go wrong again
I oh "You've shown an admirable
dedication and taking care of your"
"prisoner needs".
Not that it's necessary they're
basically inhuman.
"You probably have noticed by now that
the major remaining gripe amongst the"
"prisoners is a lack of clean clothing if
you want to take care of this need as"
"well you'll need to run a laundry
service to gradually provide all your inmates"
"with clean clothing. Build the
laundry and hire more janitors to start"
"providing clean laundry to your inmates".
yeah you'd think that'd be a necessity
god damn it do I need to do i need to do
that then
now i'm going to do the story first I
actually want to see -- actually want to
see what this is about
or, man I'll do this
do it and we can build it up here this
will probably work out better
big laundry room big laundry, big
ok so i think i got all the major
components they're just busy getting
things in there I might need more
laundry baskets though but it's getting
there. Oh look they're sleeping and they
got fresh delivered prison uniforms ohh
ohh I don't think that's it
I think they just strip down and they're
all sleeping naked that's probably what
it is or atleast as the dirty stuff and
they need to get it later but I don't
need to worry about that right now I am
worried about other things that I need
like getting power to this thing why is
there no power yet
why no power?  Why are you resting?
Why no power?
oh god I don't have enough power in the
whole building oohh
ah that's new i that's no good well I
need more power
Ooh I didn't even know that, shit ahh
crepes
um... ooh I need to build more capacitors
boink boink boinkity boink
let's try that let's get those built
please can I get those built please
because we seem to be completely out of
power everywhere and there's absolutely
not enough water because there's no
power
Shit!
oh god they can't open the doors
oh okay they got it ok they're good
they're good
we got it ok that's what we now switch
on
Oh Bom Bom Bom Bom all they can't get
out
let him out let him free please okay
there we go
all right that's done resting right on
the powerblock good move bra
good move okay so the laundry room
should be up and running very soon as
soon as they finish the electrical
development which might not happen
because that's not close enough is it
get to do like that
ok but either way the optional thing is
done so let's get to the story here
oh geez well it looks grimy
what's with the yellow stains who oh hey
how's it going
what are you doing here that really
pretty looking knife there well he's so
incredibly naked that's amazing
Oh. "Alone. 'Poifect.'"
uh-huh oh boy
why would anyone be alone in the showers
. . point at your victims step one you took
your time.
"Cut the bullshit I never did know what
that whore sister of mine saw on you"
"This her idea?  Off the old man?"
Ooh, the plot thickens
"Is that what you think you fat fuck I
didn't mean for him to get hurt"
"I love him like he's my own father I'm
sick of seeing this family brought down"
"by your stupidity".
"The fire was meant for you." Oh "Then
consider this repaying the favor"
oh oh hi
who the hell are you. "Don't come the saint"
"we both know you plan to take me out one day." oh hi
"Yeah, you always were a smart guy Nico
look for a guy you don't worry you won't"
"feel a thing".
oh "I told you watch your back."
oh gosh oh wow
well whoa Wow
"Have you met Frankie before? He's got a
unique talent with piano wire."
oh geez
whoa whoa whoa
"Honestly by the time he's finished they
think it was suicide."
how is... how would that be suicide?
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
Whoa
That went horribly awry there oohh
my goodness this game this game..this game
I love it oh he survived. "Fantastic. Looks
like the Palermo family is running out"
"of members."
wow "You can bet the Palermo's were
selling those narcotics on to every con here."
"The guards are telling me they've seen a
lot of prisoners showing signs of"
"withdrawal since the fire."
"I want you to search every prisoner in
every cell I bet we find Palermo drugs"
"all over the prison."
Well, wow oh ok we're gonna end this one
here
wow I love this game this game is
awesome
this is amazing I had no idea and i love
it
I want to know so much more about the
story but either way thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you think of the series down in the
comments below
I may do a full playthrough it i have no
idea this is just awesome but thanks
again everybody for watching as always I
will see you in the next video.  Buh-bye.
Danny let me eat with you
it's a piece of shit come on. God come on!